yo what's crazy too is when you you you
got a record you and you and fred are
kind of developing a cool little
chemistry on on records this song on
this album
caught me off guard because when i saw
you pull it out i was like oh [ __ ] gives
conway was definitely different than
what i was expecting
yeah yeah yeah talk about y'alls because
i saw y'all were out in miami together
but talk about y'all's chemistry and
like
you know i feel like griselda fred you
know
black thought you know run the jewel i
feel like there's some jedis in the game
you know what i'm saying it's like
there's the jedi club royce
there's one of them you know what i'm
saying but you and fred like i feel like
between fred and griselda y'all been
putting out the best hip-hop music for
the last
couple years what's y'alls relationship
and like
you know that chemistry has been wild on
record so far
yeah nah man and it took a while for the
for the record it took a while for y'all
to work together yeah yeah yeah yeah
i mean that's my [ __ ] like gabe is my
[ __ ] man
you know what i'm saying i got love
forgets like every time i ever you know
been around that [ __ ] or whatever it's
like it's love
show and and vice versa like anytime you
come around me i try to
you know i'm saying show the utmost love
and respect because i respect his cried
and i just respect you know the type of
[ __ ] he is you know what i'm saying
i went on tour with gabe so i got to
kind of be a little
got a little closer with him you know
what i'm saying and to be around him a
little more than i have in the past
and um i just got to see what type of
dude he is
and you know i [ __ ] with the [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying and so it was only
right like we we
we always even before like this record
um
the babies and fools all of this tape
mm-hmm and [ __ ] like that like we've
always talked and kicked it and about
doing songs doing the record doing the
tape yeah we got
man let's do a tape oh if y'all did a
tape that should be crazy exactly
exactly so but you know i mean
it just you know what what what i'm one
of them type of [ __ ] everything ain't
about rap [ __ ] all the time to me so
like if i hit you i ain't all the time
like yo i got a joint for you right yo
yo i want you to i need i need a verse
bro i need this like i don't care about
that rap [ __ ] all the time sometimes i
just be genuinely just
tapping in like what i'm brought to what
you want you guys gonna ask you because
i feel like in hip-hop i mean especially
y'all man like
you know there's
there's like very few actual friends
you'll make in the hip-hop business
absolutely tons of acquaintances tons of
people who
you'll dap up and you know what i'm
saying you'll see it shows you'll see it
events but like
actual friends that like if your rap
career went away tomorrow
that y'all would actually still be boys
right like who's on that list for you if
anybody
the list is short i'm gonna be honest
with you of course it is this is short
because you know i mean like you got to
keep in mind man a lot of these [ __ ]
cap so they just
sometimes they say [ __ ] yeah you know
cause it sounds good because you ran
into it
yeah let's do some [ __ ] you know man you
had a [ __ ] and
[ __ ] don't even answer your tracks back
but um
try to say you know rest in peace
prodigy that was
probably the prodigy was early with
y'all yeah
you know what i'm saying like rest in
peace to my boy prodigy man that was my
real friend
um rayquan
did the intro on the gazelle down that's
my real friend i like to consider us
like real friends
um royce the five nine for sure that's
my brother
like always love always love you know
what i'm saying outside of any rap [ __ ]
like
you know what i mean i look at it like
we two of the ellis lyricists
come on man you know i mean we only got
you know one or two or three songs like
because it ain't about rap it's genuine
love
um flee lord that's my brother
um i remember which project we heard
the fleece [ __ ] he snapped on that [ __ ]
though yeah yeah flea went fleas on from
king to a guy
okay we're
you know what i'm saying yo um there's
more but i
can't think right right right so if you
didn't get named don't be affected
right i'm gonna get a text damn bro you
don't [ __ ] with me like that
yeah yeah i just i'm high right now baby